these days there is an increasing trend
of using omega-3 fatty acids in your
diet
and eating oily fish because it might
have health benefits
now especially in 21st century people
are consuming
more and more omega-3 supplements for
their own health
so what is omega-3 and what is the
health benefit of
omega-3 stay tuned till the end of this
video because in this video we are going
to talk about the biology behind
omega-3 and how it is beneficial or what
is
the side effects so omega 3
are pufa pufa means polyunsaturated
fatty acid
so if we look at their structure we
would understand and three major omega-3
fatty acids are alpha-linolenic
acid echosapentanoic acid and docosa
hexanoic acid okay these names are
difficult so people call them
ala epa and dha respectively
and they are generally found from
animal sources such as seafood sea
fish etc and also the plant sources like
olive oil
many vegetables etc all of them
have something in common if you look at
their
last carbon and start from there in the
third position there would be a double
bond
unsaturation so this is specifically
known as omega-3 and in this omega-3
position there is a unsaturation that is
why these are known as omega-3 fatty
acids
so let us talk about the health benefit
of omega-3 fatty acids
so these are very important for cardiac
health
it reduces inflammation decrease the
chances of cancer
it improves the joint pain or
inflammation in the joints
it could be beneficial to reduce anxiety
and depression like symptoms
especially in case of pregnant mother it
is very good for baby's
health now omega-3 fatty acids are
effective to reduce
plasma triglyceride level it has been
seen that fish oils are rich in omega-3
and they are very important
to reduce vldl synthesis from the liver
moreover in cardiac muscle in other
muscle tissues
omega-3 fatty acids push
the system to increase fatty acid uptake
and oxidize that fatty acid in the
skeletal muscles
so all of these are benefits of omega-3
fatty acids
now let us look at their effect in bit
more details
at a cellular level so every cell has
cell membrane
now these cell membrane are composed of
phospholipids
so omega-3 fatty acid can have profound
effect on these phospholipids
and they can be incorporated in a part
of these phospholipids
they can change membrane phospholipid
composition
and thereby membrane rigidity and
membrane signaling
let me give you an example so let's say
these phospholipids
are incorporating unsaturated fatty acid
chains
so they are not too much flexible and
the membrane is less fluid
but when an omega-3 fatty acid is
incorporated in the phospholipid then
due to the kink
present in their structure it is making
the whole structure
more flexible and it would prevent the
membrane to become
compact in other words membrane fluidity
is increasing that is in turn very
important for
signaling that is happening from the
membrane surface omega-3 fatty acid
incorporation is very
crucial other than that omega the
omega-3 for
fatty acids can directly bind to
the retinoic acid receptor retinoic acid
receptor is a very important
intracellular receptor that can leads to
several gene transcription so overall
omega-3 fatty acids might have
role to play in gene transcription
it turns out that whenever our body is
affected by some kind of pathogen may be
bacteria or viruses
our macrophages or dendritic cells
work like the first line of defense so
they
try they try to engulf the pathogen and
eliminate them
and macrophage and dendritic cells
secrete inflammatory cytokine which
is kind of protection towards the body
such as il
6 and il1 but too much production of
these inflammatory cytokines could be
damaging
so omega-3 fatty acids they prevent
secretion of inflammatory cytokines from
these cell types
omega-3 fatty acid actually regulates a
crucial transcription factor nf kappa b
not shown here
but nf kappa beta inhibition leads to
less production of these inflammatory
cytokines
now another manifestation of
inflammation is actually prostaglandins
which are derived from arachidonic acids
omega-3 fatty acid can actually
inhibit prostaglandin synthesis
enzymes and thereby reducing the level
of prostaglandins
and thereby reducing inflammation
other than that these omega-3 fatty
acids they have profound effect on both
innate and adaptive immune system
in the inner immune system it decreases
cell migration cytokine production and
antigen presentation
whereas in the adaptive immune system it
decreases cell migration
proliferation and cytokine production
and also reduce the
cellular activation other than that like
it has an
overall effect of immune suppression
omega-3 fatty acids like epa and dha
they can regulate crucial transcription
factor
like ppar alpha and ppr gamma
ppar alpha activation leads to decrease
in tag and vldl secretion by a specific
signaling pathway
also fatty acid oxidation is
increased which involves ppar alpha
activation by these epa and dha
ppr gamma on other hand side can improve
insulin sensitivity or increase
tag clearance or triaxial visceral
clearance
all of these things ensures that cardiac
health is improved so overall
consumption
of omega-3 fatty acid improves your
cardiac health reduce the chances of
coronary artery disease so it's quite
beneficial right
so keeping in all of these things in
mind we should understand that
we should incorporate some amount of
omega-3 fatty acid in our diet
so don't forget to like share and
subscribe my channel and do let me know
in the comment how you like my videos
and don't forget to turn on the
notification by pressing the bell icon
thank you guys